Sir, the names of the Under Graduate and Post
Graduate students who on fulfillment of prescribed
conditions have been found eligible for the
Institute Gold and Silver Medals and for the purpose of
Gold Medals have been printed
in the Brochure published under 54 Convocation by the
Director
Student Award Gold Medal Awarded by
President of India Gold Medal to Rahul
Kumar Jagdish
Ripal
Stunner Awarded to
Dr. Bam Chandra Rai Memorial Gold Medal
Indrajit Mal N Out Student Award Awarded
to the Best Rounder Awarded by
ASU Student  Awarded by
Prime Minister of India Gold Medal Gop
Raju Shree Chakra Auto Student
Digner and MTE Course in Electronics and
Electrical Communication Engineering for
Having Highest Grade Point Average Among
Successful Students Student Degree Course of the
Year
Dr. Gyan Chandra Ghosh Memorial  Gold
Medal Kumar Pu Student Degree
Course Computer Science Student Degree Course Computer Science
Student Degree Course
Org Chand Gold Medal Arjun Sen Gupta An
Outgoing Student of the Second Year MSc
Course in Chemistry for Having the Highest
Grade Point Average Amongst Successful
Students  of AC Co of the
Year
The Director's Gold Medal Girish Gokul Dasan
An Outgoing Student of the Year MTech Course
Computer Science and Engineering for Having
the Highest Grade Point Average Most Successful
Student of the Year MTech and MCP Course of the
Year